the writers nominated for Best
Screenplay adapted from another medium
armor and a thousand a screenplay by
John Hale and Bridget Bolan adaptation
by Richard Sokolov goodbye Columbus
screenplay by Arnold Shirley Midnight
Cowboy screenplay by Waldo Salter they
shoot horses don't they
screenplay by James Poe and Robert E
Thompson
Zee screenplay by George Sempron and
Costa Gravas
the winner is Waldo
it's very exciting I want to thank all
the beautiful people who helped them
make with my cowboy most of all I want
to thank all the beautiful people were
going to see it made their number
increase
miss Ali MacGraw and I have the honor of
presenting the award to that inventive
and courageous group of artists who
write original material intended for the
screen it takes courage to be original
and for their originality these films
have been nominated for best story and
screenplay Bob and Carol and Ted and
Alice story and screenplay by Paul
Mazursky and Mary Tucker Butch Cassidy
and the Sundance Kid story and
screenplay by William Goldman the damned
story by Nicola at Lucca and Rico Mary
Olli and Luchino Visconti Easy Rider
story and screenplay by Peter Fonda
Dennis Hopper and Terry seven the Wild
Bunch story by Wallen Green and Roy n
Cigna screenplay the wall in green and
Sam Peckinpah the envelope please the
winner is William Goldman for Butch
Cassidy
thank you from vehicle